Real food, we eat in a week.
As a large family,
I cook a lot from scratch and most of our food is homemade.
We do eat out occasionally when we're in town,
um, mostly for lunch and stuff like that.
So, yeah,
both of our meals are cooked at home.
We strive to use Whole Foods
and foods that we prepare ourselves from scratch
from simple ingredients. I try to buy organic produce,
but that's something that's not a huge deal for me.
We do grow a lot of our own produce as well.
My main focus is to eat food that's not been processed
and to grow as much of our own food and meat as possible.
When gardening, we don't use pesticides or herbicides,
and we also don't spray our yard with any unnatural fertilizers,
including the grass. Um,
we do this as we have our chickens free ranging
and our cow free ranging,
so we do not want them to ingest any unnecessary chemicals,
herbicides or pesticides. Here I'm making my absolute favourite cookies,
the cookies that started it all.
This is the very first recipe I made from scratch
and I still make it 10 years later.
The ingredients have much to improve since I first started this recipe.
I use my own low butter here,
the best flour I can get at the time,
and the best brown sugar.
We started canning from the garden some spaghetti sauce.
We normally buy Rao's. If I don't Have any canned sauces?
But this year
I really wanted to make sure we have enough canned sauce
to offer for the winner. So
I'm starting at this little task
of counting as much sauce as possible.
And we ate some of this for dinner.
The kids absolutely loved it.
Making and turning your own pasta sauce is so easy.
I don't even know why I purchased it for so many years.
But knowing exactly what's in the sauce
and tweaking it for your own preference
is just the best thing you can do for yourself.
This week we have some salmon.
We don't normally eat salmon that much,
but if I eat fish, I do prefer to eat salmon.
We then ate some steaks. Um,
I think we should revise it too, though.
I can't remember. But anyway,
we ate some steaks. This is from the cow that we normally buy.
About half a cow a year. Here's some raw butter.
We go through a lot of butter.
I do still buy some butter,
but can't keep up. But I'm making butter every week.
Here's some more chicken. We have a lot of chicken in the freezer.
My favorite pot roast. I love fall and winter,
so I can make as much pot roast possible.
It is just my favourite, um,
good feeling home cooked meal.
It just gives me all the good comfy vibes.
I love to add Worcestershire sauce into the stock that I made for this
Is absolutely delicious.
I use some bone broth that I made when we got our cow,
and this just fell apart. It was so delicious.
Another go to for us is pancakes.
If the kids are hungry and breakfast,
lunch, or dinner,
pancakes solves that problem.
I'm gonna top this with some delicious
organic maple syrup that I got from Sam's Club.
Um. Yep.
And that was another week of home cooked meals.